So let's compare what we need for the conditional
moves and what we need for full predication. So for
the move instructions, if they're conditional, we need a
separate opcode that tells us this is a conditional instruction.
Usually, we have a separate opcode for each particular condition. So we need a
number of new opcodes. For full predication we use the same instructions that
we use without conditions. We add condition bits for full predication.
However, we add condition bits to every instruction.
So every instructor word contains some bits that tell
us what is the condition for writing to
the destination register. For example, the itanium instructions that
has full predication. And this is what an
add instruction would look like. It specifies the two
source registers, the destination registers, that this is an
add, and it has a field within the instruction
to specify the so-called qualifying predicate. That
is where the condition for the link, the
write or the r1 register will be found in. The titanium instruction has 41 bits,
where the least significant six bits specify
what the qualifying predicate is. The predicates in
the itanium are actually small one bit registers, so that you can do a condition
check and store the result in this 1-bit register.
And then really the six bits here tell you
which of the 64-bit conditional registers are you going
to use to determine whether to write to R1.